wie jedes jahr reagiere ich model scout
italienischer maker personelle
tierexperte lucius von und zu nützen
burg auf die gntm
2022 kandidatinnen starten wir hier
direkt mit der lieben kaschmir als
einziger sie aus kaschmir ist es meinen
schal kaschmir als 20 jahre und kommt
aus winnenden
frage ist nur ob sie den win
die zweite teilnehmerin es die emilia in
paris als die nicht so
mir ja im milieu ist 19 jahre und kommt
aus cafés das ist nämlich aus in der
schweiz perfekt geil dass sie bei
germany's next topmodel dabei ist die
nächste kandidatin ist liebe ihn
ein bisschen zu viel getrunken
steht wegen die blaue ist blinker ist 19
jahre und kommt aus nierstein es hat sie
an ihren steiner das hört sich da nicht
auch eine krankheit die man hat
lieselotte ist die nächste die wirkt auf
jeden fall schon ein bisschen älter und
ist
lieselotte h als musikerin und
lehrerinnen ihrer musikalischen karriere
kommt die rede immer wieder wird der 66
jährigen
lieselotte
66 also ich weiß nicht was ich verpasst
habe aber die waren doch gefühlt alle
nie älter als 25 oder bin ich dumm
giuliana ist sie war
blau sieht auf jeden fall ihre
kandidatin wie es 24 jahre alt und ein
lebensfroher charismatischer ich wusste
nie was kommt
es mal wieder zeit hier in der
christlichen tradition etwas von gott
den menschen geschenkt es wobei durch
das wort das wohlwollen als motivation
der gabe betont wird keine ahnung was
charismatisch das heißt christina ist
die nächste kandidatin die wärme ist ex
topmodel mit dabei ist sie ist 20 jahre
kommt aus lübeck und sie beschreibt sich
selbst als echte frohnatur
du froh
barbara ist auch mit dabei die ist auch
schon 68
also not wirklich ich will ja auch
niemanden jetzt irgendwie schlecht war
das war in der vergangenheit immer so
dass mir dann die hälfte der mediziner
muss das sei also wirklich sorry aber
noch fahren mit 68 jahren würde er sich
nicht auf die idee kommen zu sagen wo
als service ist model gönne ich mir
sie richtig krass aus 68 aber wir haben
hier zu viel stress mit den ganzen
ticken wie ich ganz ehrlich jessica ist
die nächste sie ist 21 kommt aus berlin
und an jessica lieben ihre freude
besonders ihre verrückte und ehrliche
art und dass sie immer ganz viel
positive energie mitbringen david siegel
tragen
also sie wird da könnte mich beim wort
nehmen es geht hier los war am dritten
februar die wird sich mit irgendwie nach
aare kriegen anita ist die nächste
person die ich eine kandidatin muss bei
den italienern pferde denke sie ist auf
jeden fall 20 jahre alt und kommt aus
neustadt an der donau was ist das für
eine stadt
donauwörth
[Musik]
kommt aus drei und perfekte sie kommt
aus 23 jackmans großes vorbild ist naomi
campell weil sie aus ihrer sicht einer
der schönsten und zielstrebig ssten
frauen ist
kann ja noch werden
the main rebel models laura
wb.com
sie sollen wie punkt dahinter als 19
jahre alt und kommt aus günzach
günstig
günzach
nicht den text dann schauen wir mal dass
unsere an das obere schon oft genug
durch gelesen ich möchte hashtag ihren
dm werden weil es zeit wird das ein
covergirl gewinnt
ist doch was
was ist also auch wieder nach vorn aber
was ist daran so wie sie es doch über
dünn oder luca war klar
[Musik]
jedes jahr aufs neue kommt medien am
flughafen
ist auch mit dabei sie kommen aus
böblingen in acht bis 18 jahre und kommt
aus böblingen und sie spielt seit sechs
jahren im verein handball ich hasse
handballen er seitdem ich im handball
hier so gegen bekommen und zeigt jetzt
weg aber jetzt keinen kleinen finger
mehr ganz blöd gelaufen damals du bist
du was ich geschrieben habe als elfer
gegen geflogen ist
maja finger
julia ist auch mit dabei wer hätte es
gedacht julia ist 19 und perfekte gab da
bin ich los ist natürlich nicht 19
sondern 21 jahre alt und kommt aus korea
casey ist nämlich gelernte
kosmetikerinnen bereits als schülerin
konnte sie erste erfahrungen sammelt und
sich selbst beschreibt julia als sehr
wandelbar zuverlässig ehrgeizig und
zielstrebig dich würde ich direkt mit
ins team aufnehmen
ich habe kein team laura bock jetzt was
dort sind wir oben die anderen punkt
hatte und mein gott sie sich auf die
bibi
künstlerin diana begraben start martina
dabei sie ist 50 auch schon sorry ich
will das nicht so dumm sagen von wegen
die ist schon 50 oder keine ahnung was
martina wenn du das siehst oder auch die
anderen beiden lieselotte oder wie
andere auch noch hieß wenn ihr das seht
wirklich noch front aber ich dachte
wirklich immer das gntm man muss
irgendwie unter 25 sein oder so
ein lob
ich keine ahnung ist auf jeden fall 18
jahre alt und kommt auch aus kloster
leuten
ist es die tochter
bereit das wird perfekt passen pauline
ist auch mit dabei pauline ist 18 jahre
alt und kommt aus schwerte paulin und
ihre familie sind schausteller
es nicht schauspieler
es ist die 18 jahre
hhv schneller machen zirkus so was oder
wie kühe ist auch mit dabei wiebke
musste auch direkt an seine pferde
mädchen denken gibt es ist in meinen
augen ist das ein name für mädchen die
so zu viele sofort zur erdfarbene
softshell jacken hat
dunkel grün oder braun
und auch so bis oben hin zu mit den reiz
erschossen dann noch mit seinem klett
vorne vorwissen
lisa marie ist auch noch mit dabei sie
ist auf jeden fall groß durchtrainiert
sich gerade die an wahrscheinlich dann
und reingeschrieben ja ich will auch mal
das cover model paulina ist auch mit
dabei sie ist 32 jahre alt und kommt aus
berlin sie hat dass es
hier und ist noch mehr
dass sie unten für reiter mit den fragen
der ist ehrliche frage länger als die
antwort so vieles auch noch mit dabei
die kommt aus harsewinkel oh das ist
bielefeld bei mir noch einmal um die
ecke im punkte ehrgeiz gibt sich so viel
auf einer skala von eins bis zehn eine
glatte 11
die betrifft
die wird so richtig so wenn sie wenn sie
keinen job kriegt ist sie so richtig
abgefragt auf die person die den job
dann bekommen als letzte kandidatin ist
auf jeden fall die liebe lena dies auch
noch mit dabei sie ist 21 jahre alt und
kommt aus teltow das ist wobei berlin
glaube ich lena liebt es zeit mit ihrer
familie und freunden verbringen egal ob
bei einem entspannten spiel oder
kochabend oder aber auf einer party in
einer bar oder in einem club die
bwl-studentin interessiert sich sehr für
mode und kosmetik direkt richtig